[Music]
i love kristen wiig
we have this beautiful friendship it was
an
instant connection and we have a very
similar sense of humor
wow you're so funny no one's made me
laugh like this in such
a long time gal is a great scene partner
and friend but at the same time we can
immediately go into like those scenes
where we have that sort of
super villain hero rivalry
gal and kristen would make this awesome
duo
that was pretty good it's great to see
that love and friendship blossom
it just filled me with joy gal and i
love each other
she's brilliant
[Music]
i love kristen wiig we have this
beautiful friendship
it was an instant connection and we have
a very similar
sense of humor wow you're so
funny no one's made me laugh like this
in such a long time
miguel is a great scene partner and
friend but at the same time we can
immediately go into like those scenes
where we have that sort of
super villain hero rivalry
gal and kristen would make this awesome
duo
that was pretty good it's great to see
that love and friendship
blossom it just filled me with joy gal
and i love
each other
she's brilliant
you